sofern wir das ist die nachricht des
tages
da kommt man doch gut in fahrt oder
genau atemlos in diese bild live sendung
mit dieser exklusiven meldungen sie
haben es gesehen helene fischer ist
schwanger ja sie ist der deutsche schoss
da 16 millionen verkaufte tonträger 17
echos zwei goldene kameras immer wieder
an der spitze der charts aber in ein
paar monaten da heißt es dann womöglich
atemlos in den kreißsaal die 37-jährige
wird nämlich marie
helene fischer sie ist der superstar
unter den super-stars megaerfolgreich
mega sexy und bald eine mega mama die
schlager queen macht mit ihren
spektakulären bühnenshows seit jahren
die größten arenen in deutschland voll
tausende fans beten sie an und helene
bricht in den offiziellen deutschen
charts einen rekord nach dem nächsten
[Musik]
atemlos durch die nacht ist in
deutschland das am häufigsten
heruntergeladene lied aller zeiten mit
rund einer million downloads
2004 schickt fischers mutter eine demo
cd an den künstler manager uwe kanthak
dann sehr große durch es folgen
bühnenauftritte plattenverträge tourneen
und 2014 die beziehung zu florian
silbereisen
vier jahre später die trennung und eine
neue liebe bei helene luftakrobaten
thomas seite nach monatelanger pause
kehrt helene fischer nächstes jahr bei
einem xxl konzert zurück auf die bühne
ist dabei dann aber nicht nur ex
superstar sondern auch als super mama
und recherchiert hat diese exklusive
nachricht unsere stellvertretende
chefredakteurin tanja may und sie ist
bei uns im studio alle tanja
erste frage natürlich in welchem monat
ist sie also meine information sagen
dass sie im vierten monat ist das kind
soll nächstes jahr im februar märz zur
welt kommen weißt du was darüber wie es
ihr geht meine infos sagt es geht mir
fantastisch und sie ist sehr sehr
glücklich und sie hat ja auch im juli
und im august also helene spricht ja
sehr selten privat aber sie hat bei
instagram ein paar sätze geschrieben und
da erzählt sich schon wie glücklich sie
ist und dass sie zum ersten mal im leben
so richtig bei sich ist und ihr glück
genießt und da war sie natürlich schon
schwanger das wusste man noch nicht
jetzt wissen wir warum sie innerlich und
äußerlich so straße hätte man es da
schon ableiten können hast du schon
geahnt also ich sag mal so also
baby-gerüchte bei helene fischer die
gibt es schon seit ihrer beziehung auch
mit florian silbereisen und jetzt
natürlich auch seit drei jahren seitdem
sie mit thomas seite zusammen ist sehnt
man sich nach einem baby ganz
deutschland wartet darauf dass
deutschlands erfolgreichste sängerin
mama wird das ist jetzt so von daher hat
man darauf gewartet aber das ist jetzt
wirklich passiert ist ja ich freue mich
sehr für die beiden ich glaube ich auch
immer wieder fotos wo man dann vermutete
ist da ein baby bauch oder ist da kein
gab es natürlich aber das ist gemein
wenn man ja wir wissen dass alle wenn
man dann doch mal vielleicht ein
wochenende hat oder auch mal vier wochen
hatte man sagt okay jetzt gönne ich mir
mal ein bisschen kuchen oder sie ist
gerne schokolade das hat ja auch immer
erzählt und dann gleich zu sagen okay
sie ist schwanger aber jetzt ist es
tatsächlich so
schon die ganzen mein bauch ein schweres
gerät gesagt ist aber es ist wirklich
immer gemeinde hat mir einmal was ein
business jahre gegessen hast du die
schlagzeile schwanger jetzt ist es so
und deutschland wartet auf das erste
foto natürlich also man wartet natürlich
drauf und ich vermute aber mal also
helene das haben wir auch exklusiv
erfahren helene wird ja zu wetten dass
gehen am 6 november zum zdf da wird sie
dann sitzen auf der couch und da wird
sie sich natürlich zeigen und da bin ich
sicher dass sie dann auch darüber reden
wird thomas seidl ist der vater du hast
du schon rausgehauen wir wollen ein
bisschen gucken wer ist der überhaupt
seit wann sind die beiden zusammen und
ja wie steht es um die beziehung der
beiden die wahrscheinlich jetzt für
immer ist cdm behringer die hat sie
infos über thomas und helene
jawohl wer ist thomas seidl ich
verspreche ihnen in wenigen minuten
wissen sie alles was sie über den
36-jährigen akrobaten aus eppertshausen
in hessen so wissen müssen so und wir
starten mit fotos die vor allem bei fans
das herzchen wirklich höher schlagen
lassen also zumindest wenn man team
thomas ist nicht wenn man team florian
ist aber wir sind heute natürlich team
thomas ganz klar und diese fotos die
wurden an die presse rausgebracht als
man wusste ort deutschland hat ein neues
traumpaar
2017 ist thomas zu helene sozusagen
gestossen zu ihrer crew 70 shows war mit
dabei und kurz noch sein weg bis dahin
also schon als kind war damals wohl sehr
sehr sportlich die eltern haben ihn zum
sport gebracht weil aus eigenen angaben
war als kind schon recht hyperaktiv
unterwegs um die eltern haben sich die
nachkommen junge macht sport und das war
die beste entscheidung danach mit einem
wahnsinns karriere hingelegt muss man
sagen als turner erstmal über jahre
hinweg waren auch in der bundesliga in
deutschland und in frankreich mit dabei
danach hat er sich da einen großen namen
als luftakrobatik gemacht viele viele
internationale stationen folgen bis er
dann
sie halten darf ihr händchen nehmen darf
hier den fuß auf diesem foto sie durch
die lüfte schwingen darf und dass in 70
shows wie schon gesagt habe und achtung
in bis zu neun metern höhe
ich meine für ihn hier wird es kein ding
gewesen sein aber für helle wahnsinn das
ist auch ein grund weshalb sie die fans
übrigens auch so lieben dass sie da
natürlich immer so gas gibt so und jetzt
hier sehen hier vor allem hier in der
mitte fast das ganze paket möglich sagen
dass ich ihr lehne fischer auch
tatsächlich so verknallt hat kann man
bei diesen fotos verstehen seit ende
2018 sind die beiden ein paar also 2017
ist er zu dem schluss gekommen seit ende
2008 sind die beiden zusammen und fast
nichts in der öffentlichkeit es gibt
kaum auftritte und obwohl ja thomas sein
geld auf der bühne jetzt zuletzt auch
verdient hat scheint er überhaupt keinen
bock auf medienrummel zu haben denn
sobald die zwei zusammen gekommen sind
es öffentlich wurde
wirklich alles es gibt keine social
media accounts mehr von ihm und auch
seine website alles weg so umso
überraschender dann dieser auftritt hier
aber 2019 da hat er sich raus getraut
ins scheinwerferlicht ist schön über den
catwalk gewackelt 2009 10 war das da
sind auch ganz ganz viele promis auch
mitgelaufen aber man hat wirklich nur
auf gekuckt an diesem tag und das ist
eben so wenn man sich rar macht dann
versucht man da auch wirklich jeden
schnipsel zu bekommen und das schöne ist
auch live zuschauer das netz vergisst
nie und so konnten wir auch eine schöne
geschichte von ihm aus kramen denn 2008
da hat auch tatsächlich einen lustigen
weltrekord auf die beine gestellt er hat
nämlich geschafft in fünf minuten
achtung
82 unterhosen übereinander zu stülpen
und zu tragen weltrekord muss man auch
erst mal schaffen oder sarah bestimmen
sehr sehr lustig aus aber jetzt kommen
wir erst mal zurück zu helene ein paar
ikonische fotos ikonisch nenne ich sie
einfach habe ich für sie rausgesucht
hier weltmeisterschaft 2014 mit unseren
jungs sie hat sie wirklich befeuert ist
auf die bühne gegangen hier hat sie
sogar den pokal in der hand singt
natürlich atemlos atemlos übrigens auch
dieser mega sixpack oder wahnsinns
figurale leben der fischer möchte ich
bei diesem bild an dieser stelle auch
einfach mal sagen so dann geht's weiter
hier als schauspielerin hat sie sich
auch mal versucht mit dunklen haaren
erkennt man fast gar nicht beim tatort
vase dabei mit til schweiger und dieses
foto ist tatsächlich beim ersten drehtag
entstanden
hier geht's weiter mit james blond
einmal james blunt einmal und auf der
rechten seite mit udo jürgens und das
war wirklich tatsächlich nur vier tage
vor seinem tod also emotionales foto
auch ergibt hier noch ein küsschen auf
die hand sehr sehr schöner auftritt bei
ihrem weihnachtskonzert
2014 auch und dann haben wir sie hier
auch nochmal äußerst sympathisch
irgendwie haar lässt sie sich das
eiskalte wasser über den körper
schmeißen die eisbox challandes war es
damals sie erinnern sich wahrscheinlich
noch und das ist ein foto was wirklich
symbolisierte ich bin mir für nichts zu
schade und ich glaube thomas es sich
auch für nichts zu schade denn ich habe
im interview gelesen hatten sie sich
fest vom oberbürgermeister aus etwa 1000
und der erklärt nämlich wie toll und
willi thomas ist also ich glaube das
wird ein traum kind oder was meint ihr
ich gebe zurück
wir sind gespannt saßen wir sind
gespannt wie es aussehen wird und die
frage natürlich folgt dann auch die
große hochzeit ich bin ganz sicher dass
die beiden heiraten werden ob sie das
jetzt vor der geburt noch macht oder
danach weiß ich nicht aber hochzeit wird
auf jeden fall geben
[Musik]